Bon! bah merci
Alors est-ce que vous pourriez m'imprimer
deux attestations, s'il vous-plaît?
oui bien sûr, alors je vous imprime ça tout de suite
Par contre j'ai plus d'encre
je suis désolé
C'est pas grave !
Ah bon ?
Parce que petite fille,
il existe trois héros
le monde est tellement beau
Ils sont rouge, bleu, jaune
jaune, bleu, rouge
Ils sont rouge et jaune, jaune et bleu !
Ils viennent pour les jours heureux
Ils font le A4
Et pourtant, ils sont 3
Tout le monde a leur nom en bouche
Ton cœur est en joie
Car ils viennent te meeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeettre
Une cartouuuche
Bah vas-y !
Ouvre le clapet, ils arrivent là !
-Ah bon ?
J'le fait, Thierry ?
-Vas-y !
Ah oui
D'accord...
*Mots japonais*